Now on to another new addition to UE5, the state tree.
So what is a state tree?
In short, they're a general purpose
hierarchical state machine.
They combine the selectors from behavior trees
with states and transitions that you would usually see
in state machine architectures.
States are arranged in a tree structure
and these states contain evaluators, tasks,
and transitions which we're all gonna discuss shortly.
A selection of states can be triggered
at any location on the tree
but it initially starts from the root of the tree.
In order to create a state tree asset however,
you must first select a schema for your state tree
and current schemas are available.
The first one being the mass state tree
and the last one being the state tree component.
Let's take a look at the anatomy of a state tree.
First of all, in figure one, we have the root
and this is the first state selected
when the state tree is running.
Next in figure two, we have the selector state
and this refers to a state that has child states.
This state will never be selected directly
and selection will continue to one of its child states.
In figure three, we can see the state enter condition
and this refers to the list of conditions
that determine when a state can be selected.
In figure four, we have a task
and this refers to a set of actions
that belonged to a state
and are executed when the state becomes active.
Lastly, we have transition
and this defines the condition
that triggers the state selection process.
A transition is triggered when a task completes,
succeeds or fails or when a monitor condition succeeds.
A state contains a list of conditions
which must be met in order
to consider the state for activation.
During the selection process,
each state's conditions are evaluated.
If they pass, then the selection process proceeds
to the state's child states if there are any.
If there are no child states,
then the state itself will be activated.
Each state consists of evaluators, tasks and transitions.
The data in the state tree flows from root to its leaves.
This means the data exposed by any state
will be available for the other states down the tree.
It's important to note that when a state is selected,
it will activate all of the states
from the root to the leaf state.
All tasks are executed for all active states,
starting from the root down to the selected state.
A state can contain multiple tasks
that are all run concurrently
for as long as the state remains active.
A task in a state tree is similar in concept
to tasks in a behavior tree.
A task is an action that is executed
when its owning state is activated.
It provides an output to the state tree.
Some common examples would be the selection of a target
or the playing of an animation.
All tasks inside a state will run concurrently.
Once the first completes, it will trigger a transition
which can result in the selection of a new state entirely.
Global tasks provide a way to run regular tasks
that are associated with the tree
rather than a specific state.
These tasks can contain variables
and execute custom code when the tree starts,
ends, and ticks.
Gathered data can be used during state selection
and will be available, as the name suggests,
globally throughout the state tree.
For example, we could have a global task
that determines the current time of day.
Since the global tasks are started
before the root state in the tree,
this information would be available when the tree starts
and during the first state selection.
If this state tree was controlling an AI,
the state selection could result in different behavior
during the night versus the day.
A transition is pretty self-explanatory.
It can point to another state in the tree
which will trigger a state selection process once again.
A transition can contain trigger conditions
that need to be met before the transition can occur.
Transitions are evaluated starting with the leaf state
and progressing upwards towards the root.
During this process, the first transition that succeeds
and leads to a state selection will be selected.
This hierarchy allows for grouping of common transitions.
Completion transitions, however, now trigger at the state
where the task that is completed is located.
For example, if the execution is currently
at root guard leaf and the task at guard state completes,
transitions on guard and root are handled skipping leaf.
It's important to note that tick
and event triggered transitions will have a precedence
over completion transitions.